[Applaudissements]
on va parler des gens crier dans la rue
oh my god oh my god
certains l'ont crié d'autres étaient
plus sidérés
tous les montréalers ont entendu le
craquement des branches qui ont cédé par
milliers sous le poids du verglas
environ 30 mm accumulées en quelques
heures ce mercredi 5 avril et le premier
impact ce sont les coupures de courant
la carte dépanne sur l'île de Montréal
n'a presque pas des rougi en 24 heures
près d'un Montréal et sur deux a été
plongé dans le noir le froid et la peur
de manquer de pile on va aller charger
les ordinateurs chez les voisins qui ont
de l'électricité parce qu'ils pourraient
rester encore un tiers des pannes à
résorber dans 48 heures soyez patient
soyez patients c'est pas du tout comme
le vergload 1998 d'abord parce qu'on est
en avril et non en janvier la mairesse
de Montréal qui invitait à la prudence
désir soir était sur le terrain aux
côtés des deux premiers ministres à
l'appel à la collaboration citoyenne
pour déplacer les véhicules je vous le
dis il y a pas de contravention
aujourd'hui
c'est dégager les rues comme celle-ci
bloquée par un tilleul de 40 ans qui a
fini sa vie affaissée sur un duplex ou
sur cet artère névralgique où les
émondeurs s'activent en plein heure de
pointe autant de symptômes du même mal
selon le Premier ministre les événements
météorologiques extrêmes seront plus
fréquents on peut évidemment pas
attacher un événement spécifique au
changement climatique mais l'ensemble on
sélectionne réalité la question de
l'adaptation des villes se posera de
nouveau après cette autre tempête
marquante c'est important de bien
entretenir nos armes c'est pour ça que
lors de notre dernier budget on a
augmenté nos équipes de montage enfin à
la ville on a une belle épinette ici sur
la rue qui on trouve ça triste de voir
de perdre ses arbres-là des arbres qui
ont fait beaucoup de dommages et les
citoyens ont un temps limité pour
demander réparation sur les sites
montréal.ca il y a le bureau des
réclamations vous avez 15 jours suivant
l'événement et vous devez prouver qu'il
y a eu un dommage une faute et un lien
entre les deux
et certains réclameront aussi un morceau
de souvenirs de ce verglas 2023 c'est
quand même un beau morceau que j'ai
l'impression que avec un peu de travail
on va faire une belle table extérieur
avec ça on n'est pas en état d'urgence
insiste les autorités mais en situation
d'urgence c'est d'ailleurs plusieurs
centaines de places d'hébergement sont à
disposition de ceux à qui il manquera
encore l'électricité ce soir et demain
on attend des températures négatives
dans les 24 prochaines heures si
Matthieu Prost Radio-Canada Montréal